il y avait également du football sur les
terrains de maurepas ce week end en
tournoi international était organisée
sur les quatre terrains du stade du bout
des clots 60 équipes dont trois
formations belges et plus de 700 joueurs
âgés de 10 à 16 ans se sont affrontés
pour cette 21e édition
on écoute tout de suite il va voir que
le président de l'ajs maurepas et en des
visiteurs il était au micro de willial
williams elle part dans ce dimanche
globalement on rencontre deux équipes
par rapport au championnat qu'on fait
tout au long de l'année et basse et
montrer son football et voilà reprend
qu'on est aussi aussi fort même avec des
équipes étrangères et de montrer voilà
que ben corps qu'on pratique à mon
football à maurepas et d'autres équipes
même proche bois aussi ce qui se passe à
l'étranger parce que le jeune et est
totalement différent